there's been some noise over the past
week about and a paper that's come out
and an explorer the papers called port
contention for fun and profit people be
referring it Sportsmaster what it does
is it actually you were open ssl running
and it's using a private key and you've
got another prone which they call that
spy program which runs alongside it and
is able to extract the private key from
the open ssl program even though it
shouldn't be able to do that so i
thought it was interesting to have a
little chat about the way it's
exploiting the cpu so again light
spectrum meltdown and quite a few of the
exploits that have turned up over the
past year its exploiting the fact that
people have tried to make the CPUs run
faster and faster and sort of squeeze
every last ounce of speed after the
actual cpu technology that's there and
what this is specifically targeting is
what's put into most intel cpus and AMD
which is hyper threading so what is
hyper threading well normally when we
think about a computer system we have a
cpu in there and originally that CPU
would xq one single stream of
instructions and process data with them
you could have two CPU was in there's
got some multiprocessor system or a
multi-core system depending on how you
wire them up and then you could have two
separate streams of instructions being
executed and the way that those CPUs are
designed is you have three stages that
each instruction has to sort of go
through that in the cpu that's for them
it's a smaller stage but we can think
about this of three broad stages we have
to sort of fetch the instruction from
memory then we decode it to work out
what we actually wanted to do and then
we execute it and to make the cpu run as
fast as possible then you end up with
various execution units in your cpu
which do various things there might be
an algorithmic and logic unit which will
do addition and subtraction and various
logical operations there might be bits
that can load and store values from
memory there might be bits that can do
various other sorts of calculations
multiplications and so on address
calculations floating point operations
vector processing and so on so you have
lots of these execution units in your
machine and one of the things he got was
sort of a superscalar architecture wage
fetch two instructions and execute them
at the same time providing that they
were using different parts that you
could sort of fetch a value from memory
while adding a value onto another
register as long as they're using
separate registers and so on so the idea
is you've got if we sort of draw a
picture you've got some sort of logic
here it will call decode and you've got
going into that a stream of instructions
coming from memory so you're actually
there when you're feeding them in there
and this is actually breaking them up
into a series what we call micro
operations that do different things so
one x86 instruction may get broken up
into multiple micro operations for
example to load a value from memory add
that value onto a value in a register
and store that result out back into the
same memory location it's all three
operations so it gets split so which use
different execution that operations some
have to happen sequentially some can be
done in parallel depending on what you
doing so we end up with a series of
execution operation so let's say we've
got an ALU and we might have say a
division unit in there we might have
another one with an ALU it might have
some things to do vector type stuff
we've got another one which has got
another ALU and a multiplication unit on
there and there's various ports that
these are connected to so you've got a
sort of port one here which connects to
this set of operations port two will say
here and this is a generalized version
which is connected to these operations
these physical ports like physical wires
and they'll be parts with inside the CPU
so the way that things are connected up
and this block is a sort of scheduler
which is getting the decode Ian's
microbes from this section and sort of
sending them to the right ports as
they're being as they're available and
so on to cause the right operations to
happen in the best order to make most
you to the system you'd have a few more
over here that says has got a load port
and so on so what you can do is you can
start pulling the multiple instructions
here and as long as they're not
depending on values that previous
instructions have created and haven't
completed yet then you can sort of share
do them on different parts
the unit so if he had one instruction
which adds father one - ax you could put
it under this port the next insert is
adding something onto B EBX
you could put it onto that port there
registers within the CPU and they could
execute at the same time but the problem
you've got is that sometimes you get a
sequence of instructions which either a
sequential so you add one to a value in
a register then you multiply that
register by two and then so I mean
you've got to execute them and things
and so you can't always make full use of
your available execution units down here
in the CPU so the idea which happened
many many years ago and sort of fell out
of favor and then was brought back with
the Pentium 4 in the mid 2000s and has
existed through on various CPUs both
from AMD and Intel is cyber 13 you say
well ok this is only a single core but
let's make it present itself as if it
was - cause - to logical cause we've got
one physical core with one set of
execution units but we have it appear to
the operating system was two logical
cores so the operating system can have
two as far as its concerned two
independent bits programs threads
whatever executing on there and so there
were two streams of instructions
executing and so we'd have another
stream of instructions coming in to the
decode logic and then the CPUs got a
better chance of keeping things running
at the same time because you can either
run an instruction from here but if you
can't read you that it might be out of
scheduled instruction from the other
stream of instructions you may get some
interesting things so for example on
this one that we've drawn we've only got
one multiplier we've only got one load
and store unit if we have both of these
trying to do a multiply then one will
have to wait for the other to complete
and the sort of way that CPU might do
that it's a sort of round-robin that the
first clock cycle this one gets the
multiply on the second clock cycle that
one will get the multiply and so on so
that's the basic idea behind hyper 13
you've got two logical processors that
are used by the operations to shed you
all the jobs on your computer but
they're executed by one physical core on
the CPU so hyper threading is different
to multi-threading so multi threading is
the idea that you split your program or
your probes into multiple threads of
operation
and then they get scheduled either by
the operating system on two different
CPU cores if you've got multiple ones or
onto one single core by sort of exiting
a bit of third one than a bit of thread
to you than a bit of threads three
effectively like you could watch
multiple programs on YouTube at once by
chopping between the different programs
and watching sort of bits after the
other be quite garbled watching multiple
computer files in that sort of way so
unlike a normal photograph in a very
basic sense if you've got Bletchley Park
so that's a way of doing things in
software and programming yeah it's hyper
threading is a bit more Hardware so the
idea is there okay well you've got these
different threads of execution okay if
you've got multiple cores multiple
processing units then you can share your
each of those threads onto each of the
cores and have the message at the same
time but a few limitations on access to
memory and things because and so on with
hyper threading you say okay we'll have
the idea we got two threads of execution
happening at the same time but we've
actually only got one physical set of
units to do it so it's the hardware
that's doing the shoujo thing because
you can do it a finer grain than the
operating system can the operating
system is still scheduling across those
two logical cores but the hard work and
then say well actually this is what
trying to multiply this is trying to add
I can run them at the same time whereas
this is trying to multiply and this is
trying to multiply I need to sequence it
so it can actually start to do a finer
grain sort of threading operation and
sort of knit them together so where's
the problem come in that so the problem
comes in the let's say we've got a
program where we want to find some
information about what it's doing let's
say this program here we want to know
what sort of instructions is executing
well what we could do for example is if
we wanted to find out if it was
executing multiply instructions on the
example we've got here we've only got
one multiply unit so if this is trying
to execute multiple instructions and
this is trying to execute multiply
instructions then they're going to have
to take turns to execute those
multiplying actions on the other hand if
the one we're trying to find out on
isn't executing multiply instructions
then this one will be able to execute
multiple instructions one after the
other so what the port smash paper have
done is that they've written there
that will execute certain types of
instructions in a loop so they have a
repetition of about 64 let's say it's
these various different ones but so is
the 64 add instructions to make use or
all the Al used on Intel CPU this four
of them that it can make use of say just
for continuous as we should all likes
cute at the same time if nothing else
was running on that CPU and it times how
long they take to execute it does that
and it gets an idea of how long they
take to execute and then you run the
same thing at the same time as the other
program is running and if it takes more
time to execute than the other program
then you know that program must be also
executing some add instructions and so
what you can do is by looking at which
of these bits are being used by running
instructions then you can find out what
type of instructions are being executed
on the other side now the reason why
it's called port smash is because we've
drawn this a time one multiply it but
that's also on the same part as an ALU
for example and what they actually do is
that these are all connected to one port
of the scheduler within the CPU and so
if we wanted to say use the multiply bit
at this CPU then we have to run out of
port 2 which means the ALU on port 2
can't be used as well
can use one of the things in this column
same for example here if we want to use
a divide we can't do any ALU pressing or
vector processing so we could run
instructions that we know will tie up
one of these specific ports or will tie
up a group of them and then we can see
whether the other program providing we
can get it scheduled onto the same
physical execution unit which isn't
impossible to do is also trying to use
parts of the system on that point what
the port smash example program does is
cleverly uses certain instructions which
tie up a particular port on the CPU core
to see whether that one is being used by
the other program and by measuring the
time we can see whether that has been
done so we've got this side channel
where we can see we can get insight into
what the other process is doing as a
black box we say ok it must be trying to
execute this type of instructions
because it's interfering with our use of
this port or it isn't
failing with this use of this port so
what they do is that they run this
alongside OpenSSL doing its encryption
of the task that's been set to do and it
can measure what type of instructions
it's trying to execute what it ends up
with is a series of timing system that
shows how long things are taking the
particular points or sometimes it be
running it full-speed some points it'll
be running slower and that gives it what
they call a noisy signal which some
signal person they apply to it they can
use to actually extract the private key
that was being used by open SSL purely
from watching the timings that are going
there so what they've demonstrated is
that by running a program they can sort
of monitor enough information because
they can see what the other CPU is doing
by what their program is doing I if the
other program is trying to multiply at
the same time as they're trying to
multiply and there's only one multiply
unit that it will slow both programs
down and you can detect that they can
start to work out what operations the
other program must be doing and then
start to work out what that would mean
in terms of what that program is doing
and backtrack from that to actually
extract information that ideally they
shouldn't be able to access so the
upshot of this is that one of the
recommendations is that perhaps in
certain circumstances you might want to
turn off hyper-threading either
completely and just go back to having
four physical cores that only execute
for separate threads rather than for
physical cores executing eight logical
threads or the very least modify things
for the operating system it has the
ability to turn hyper-threading on and
off on each processor core depending on
what process is running on this because
for some processes it doesn't matter and
extracting information from it wouldn't
be that important but from others use of
encryption programs you really don't
want this sort of side channel there is
its operating system specific or is this
what's the deal there then it's not
operating system specific it will be CPU
specific so the example they've got is
for the Intel skylake in KB Lake CPU
families you could probably do something
similar with other CPUs that implement
hyper threading you would have to
calibrate your system depending on that
but that's not a problem it's not
implementation specific you just have to
tailor it to the machine are you looking
at is it a practical thing for hackers
to do this I mean the example codes
there you can download it off get up run
it and Det run the demo on a Linux
machine I don't have one with the right
sort of CPU here to demo it
unfortunately there is potential to do
this there are limitations on what you
can do with it you need to have your spy
program running on the same physical
core as the other program otherwise you
won't have full access to the
information I'm sure in the right
circumstances you could use it to get
information out if it hasn't already
been done so if we hit this boom it goes
off and sets a few things up the screen
goes black but if I switch back to my
other one right I see you again
it's logged me in as routes and of
course